all right Knicks
Nick so where are you from originally
I've been in Southern California my
whole life I was born and raised in the
Inland Empire and spent the better part
of a decade in Bakersfield before moving
to Long Beach
tell me about how you grew up
um my
my parents well my my biological father
was not in my life I had one stepfather
that
when he left my life it was very
devastating and then another stepfather
that
he was a
very classic malignant narcissist and uh
my mother who was the only constant in
my life was also a covert narcissist
though she'll never admit to that but um
so I was raised in kind of an upper
middle class environment with
very suppressive and abusive parents not
necessarily in the physical sense but
all in the emotional sense
um and I had
multiple sexual traumas growing up uh
that
like kind of uh influenced me today
ironically in a good way in the sense
that they helped me be more empathetic
to a lot of different people
the there's actually been moments when
I've cried because I feel bad because my
abusers were also abused and I
you know I sympathize for them in that
sense it's great that you're able to see
it that way
most most people are quick to hate I and
I think I have my own
dash of bitterness the the years have
bestowed upon me but I am I am actively
fighting through that as best as I can
because
I really don't like being angry all the
time
and that's that's kind of why I I always
choose to look at things in an
empathetic sense I want
to be able to understand people
but when I understand them it means you
have to also understand their pain and I
I relate so much to so many different
people's pain that it just I kind of
take it on myself
to not being angry
exactly and forgiveness is hard when
you're trying to actively when you're
trying to force yourself to forgive
it's not something that you can make
yourself do you have to get to that
point you have to make the decision you
want to do it and then take the process
which means feeling the the anger to a
certain extent you have to express it
and feel it to be able to get past it
and I think that that's the hardest part
for me as well just because it's
it's not something I like doing it's not
something I like feeling and so allowing
myself to express that is very hard
so
what kind of teenager were you
I was oof I was a weird kid I was I was
the chubby kid in my class all in
elementary school middle school and in
high school I you know was the girl with
braces that didn't fit into any group
and I didn't have a lot of friends my
parents didn't let me go out and do a
lot of stuff I didn't get into a lot of
trouble
um I was really suppressed and lonely as
a teenager I was by myself like 99 of
the time and
um
I I mean I didn't even lose my virginity
until I was 18.
and like this same month I tried weed
alcohol and lost my virginity all
together and that was after I had left
my parents house when I was 18 and uh so
I mean before then very just kept myself
like kind of the kid that was always
listening to her headphones and just
very like suppressed is really the only
word that I can think of to describe how
I would see myself back then
because I've always been a very
emotional person
and emotions were not rewarded within my
household so
you've engaged in this fetish lifestyle
now as an adult
yes how long has that been going on uh
well I was introduced to polyamory first
at the age of 24. I had actually already
had my son
um that earlier in the year and
um I met this girl on I think it was
okay Cupid of all a random site but
on there
um I met her and we act I was actually
looking for friends at the time and she
kind of introduced me to this whole idea
of what polyamory was and I remembered
in high school
I always had a list of people that I was
crushing on at the time it was never
just one person that I was solely
focused on and
because of that like I always got called
like boy crazy
and you know I I always felt very
ashamed about it and when she kind of
brought up to me the idea that her and
her partner
um had other partners that didn't
necessarily all have to co-mingle and
all this other stuff I was like wait so
you can like more than one person and
not be a bad person and it was like I've
been introduced to it a whole different
idea because monogamy is so shoved down
your throat in in our culture and
society that like I didn't actually even
comprehend that there was another option
that was okay
and so I started kind of like
indulging a little bit into the
lifestyle my prior relationship who I
was also with at the time he was very
insecure
um and began to be physically abusive
later on in the relationship and
we didn't have a dynamic of anything
that I would consider healthy polyamory
like it was
like a one penis policy and then there
was also the fact that like he was very
controlling but then wouldn't take
control of anything so he did nothing he
was very lazy and so I was constantly
you know picking up the pieces you know
especially with the kids and stuff and
so I didn't feel like I really started
to indulge
in the fetish lifestyle until
I want to say
um 2020 although we had been poly for
about eight years prior to that
but I didn't really get to experience
what a real polyamorous relationship
would be like until much later
a lot of men seem to enjoy polyamory in
their lives but they do it in secret
right whereas a lot of women when women
does it
things don't go so well for and that
happens so often I mean it it baffles me
how polyamory is looked down upon so
much when cheating is so readily
accepted in so many different like
uh Social Circles that I've been in and
it's like how can you
like what about the honesty part of it
is it that turns you off from all of
this like that's the part that for me I
love being able to share that part of
myself
with my partner like and because I I'm a
dork that loves like falling in love and
so when I have a partner that I'm in
love with that I can share a new love
with that is just like The Best of Both
Worlds and it's like but I I've never
liked cheating like it's
but it's so accepted amongst men
and like that just as a culture just
like it's expected that men are gonna
cheat like my my family used to tell me
all men leave
and that's so terrible to say and it's
one of those like
we as a society don't accept people
and then wonder why everyone doesn't
feel accepted
and it's it it baffles me because you're
absolutely right that it's especially as
a female like being able to come out and
say I enjoy multiple partners well now
you're labeled as a [__] immediately and
it's one of those well now that doesn't
seem fair because a guy can be having
sex with his wife and have an affair and
not be considered a [__]
so where's where is the boundary there
is it like
I seem to be missing the the concept of
but it's not fair it's not but most of
most of our society isn't fair towards
men or women I mean
uh men can't use sex toys and not be
stigmatized for it which I think is
ridiculous because I I don't see
anything I don't understand what the
difference between a [__] pocket and a
dildo is they're the same thing for
different gender and not even different
genders but different like you know
types of orgasm for different people and
it's like
I don't understand why men can't use
because I've I've been with people who
use sex toys like [__] rings and um the
like penis pumps and it gets very
engorged it's very big after that and
it's like it's not necessarily it's
gonna make your dick bigger but what it
does is it gives you the different
Sensations and it gives you all these
other kinds of like experiences and it's
like why aren't we readily accepting
that whereas women can have things like
the rabbit and like a woman knows
exactly what the rose is and what the
rabbit is it's because we as females are
expected to get those
but like men can't and I don't
understand that at all but it's maybe
that's why men cheat
exactly because most most men don't
think that they can go to their partner
and say hey
I am sexually fantasizing about having
you and another woman
and have that woman go awesome let's go
find The Other Woman and like I suppose
that's one of the things about me that
makes me very
unique I guess to a certain extent not
unique as in I'm the only one but in a
societal standpoint not a lot of people
like me exist where I'm just like yes
let's go and I'm primarily like on the
website that we're on
uh I want a female partner for myself as
actually what I'm looking for and
because
men are in my DMs all day long and I
while I have had some uh sexual
interactions with other guys it's more
about finding that sexual and emotional
connection with another woman that I'm
like I'm you know hoping for I have I
have never found a sexual partner that
like satisfies me as much as my fiance
does I've literally never been with
someone who indulges in all of my
different kinds of like Kinks and things
like that and is readily willing to
indulge in more of them
like at the drop of a hat
um whereas
for me I think that there could be so
much more that we could both have
both in and out of the bedroom
that
I want to like facilitate for us with
you know another partner but
I just I also like
love that idea of being with a woman
because there's something about that
emotional aspect of she's just so soft
and and like cuddly and like just I
enjoy cuddling and like kissing on women
whereas like guys enjoy kissing on me
and I'm like oh like I've had so many
bad experiences with dudes so it's it's
one of those like I just want to like
give out a female that like love and
like affection that I know that we all
crave a little bit like because of the
way Society does treat us we all kind of
are looked at
in a certain light of like delicacy and
it's like I know you're not delicate I
know that you're just gorgeous and that
you've never believed when a guy says it
because I know I don't and so it's
it's kind of like a weird societal
aspect to it but at the same time my own
personal desires mixed in with it does
that make sense so I mean the whole you
can't really ever hope for total
fairness because like if you brought
home a another girl
your fiance would probably think oh
that's kind of fun
whereas if he brought home another dude
that's a whole nother thing I don't know
see for me that's actually
it's weird because I know that I'm
pansexual for him but he's straight but
even if he borrow home another guy and
like it was the for for me no for him
um
yeah it's hard for me to put myself in
that headspace only because he's he's so
heterosexual that's why I'm saying this
whole thing is just a stupid argument no
no I like the idea because because men
don't bring home other men women can
bring your guys almost hope their girl
brings home another girl you know what
though but there's a whole like
subsection of like men who are on the DL
it says you know and it's like there's a
lot of them they would love to bring
home another man but they don't feel
like that they would ever be accepted to
do so and I'm on that like very
secretive I'm on this that train where
it's like hey if that's what you want
bring them home like I'm fine with that
I actually wouldn't have a problem with
it like personally I I think they and
we've actually explored it and like
that's how I know how heterosexual he
really kind of is more like
heteroflexible but it's it's one of
those like I know that that's not
something he would do that's why I
wasn't in that headspace but if he did I
would want to facilitate that just as
much
like that's actually not something that
would bother me in the slightest
because I think that sexual like
expression no matter what the form is
should be accepted and I know that like
the bisexual Community as a whole is
kind of looked at like oh you're just
not fully out of the closet yet or oh
you're just confused and it's one of
those like
well I don't agree with that at all and
so
I think for for my perspective that's
not something that would be a problem
but
um and he's not necessarily having to
engage when I do bring a female home
it's one of those like if it's for me
it's for me and he's cool with that
because I actually have a girl that I
see semi-regularly and it but she's not
interested in him and so it's it's been
a fun Dynamic trying to work that one
out but it's also something that he like
I said because he's so willing to
indulge me in all of my desires in that
and you know especially the sexual
desires that it's not really even a
problem for either of us
does it hurt or
enhance your relationship with him when
you're bringing home other partners
female
um
I think that depending on the way that
we both approach it it could do bows
because I know that we've both had
kind of a rocky relationship start and
we hit between the last our last
relationships were both very traumatic
and because of that we
we tend to have our own toxic responses
and Trauma responses to it
and we've done things that we're both
not proud of in that sense and
I think the fact that we're so in love
that we've decided to continue a
relationship after some of the things at
the very beginning that we've both like
done
it's
it's coming to the table with something
of an understanding for one another now
because we see where
we can be
where we can have fault and where we can
kind of like
be that's what I'm looking for it's like
a a risk to one another
um because we've both been so hurt by
our prior relationships that we don't
want hurt anymore so we're very guarded
but at the same time we want to protect
the other person
while protecting ourselves so it's it's
as long as we're open in our
Communications it's enhanced or you know
exponentially our relationship but I
think it's been the times when
we have a hard time opening up to the
other person because of that fear and
that shame that Creeps in of like fetish
world you know it comes down to that's
the time that it can actually hurt our
relationship too
there's so many options out there for
couples now that it just becomes a a lot
more than there used to be very
complicated landscape very much
what other
things have you gotten into
well uh so recently uh we've been
indulging uh the past about year I've
had a PornHub account and so we've been
filming and we've been doing we've done
a couple professional things when it
comes to that as well but
um
and we we enjoyed that very much uh I
personally loved taking pictures before
I met him
um and so that was something that I kind
of like wanted to continue and he's
slowly kind of gotten engrossed by it as
well while we
um have been performing but in the past
I want to say a month or two we've
started doing
um oh and I always pronounce this one
exhibitionism
and where we're we've discovered that we
love being watched like just by other
people we went to a party
and um
I was we I was like one of like two
females that was that were there it was
us as a couple and then another couple
and there was like 10 other guys very
uncomfortable like because it was
supposed to be many other people than
that but I ended up laying on the bed
and
um he put on a demonstration with some
of the bondage uh like I think he used
the flogger the
um
the paddle and then the
it's the other like uh Whip and I cannot
think of the name of it all sudden but
um
so but he we've been using different
kinds of uh toys and stuff like that but
he he put on a demonstration in front of
everyone uh with the blind while I had
the blindfolds on and that was that was
extremely fun
especially because you hear all the
commentary in the background and people
just like you know adjusting in their
seats and all this other stuff and it
was like that's that's really a fun like
little turn on like just to know that
people are watching and that they are
getting just as much enjoyment out of it
as I am
how have you guys been together
uh almost three years
yeah we uh we met in July of 2020.
do you guys see your
appetite for fetish Behavior expanding
or is it kind of what it is oh no it's
it's definitely expanding see because I
I have not indulged enough into it to
know what I like or dislike so there are
certain things that like intrigue me but
I'm not sure if I would actually enjoy
the actual Act of that thing but and
then there's things that have surprised
me during
um during our first uh swap you know as
a swinging kind of couple
um
watching him have sex with them with
this other female was
so arousing and so like just I was so
into it that I was I was taken aback
because I was like I'm like I can be
kind of a jealous person I was not
expecting to love watching him do that
so much given my jealousy aspects and so
because of that I was just kind of like
oh that is something that I didn't think
that I would enjoy and I do and because
of that now a whole other door of being
able to watch without having to swap or
being able to have like just other women
come in but I don't have to engage I can
just it has become a whole other aspect
that now I have new experimentation to
look into to see if I like it and that
there's still that possibility I won't
but I know that
that's something I want to explore now
and with him it's been the fact that
polyamory is even a thing like his like
I said he had been in only monogamous
relationships so for him it's expanding
into see it had started with the
emotional expansion but now the sexual
expansion and being able to have me
there is is something huge for him there
there have been you know we've never
physically cheated on each other or
anything like that but there's been
times when he was talking and I was
talking to other people and we weren't
sharing that with one another and it
made it it made it feel terrible has he
watched you with another male partner
um well when we did the swap uh for sure
um I'm trying to think oh and then yeah
uh there was it wasn't um where he just
watched he was also experiencing but I
have been in uh two
um male male female uh threesomes with
him at this point
and we've been in
one female female male
a threesome
I'm trying to think if there was another
one no no I'm sorry there were two there
were two for that and then
um but mostly we've done swaps with uh
other couples and there's been two or
three of those as well
um
I think that's about it though as far as
the sexual like actual expansion is gone
although we we have another couple
that's going to come over like this
evening I'm gonna make dinner and we
were gonna swap with them they're in
town and they we like meeting the new
people and like kind of trying to set
stuff up it's kind of like a one in
every five actually lands and we you
know meet up with them or something but
it's it's given us like an aspect of
social life that we we both kind of lost
during covid and during our trauma
responses that we kind of just like
became reclusive and we're both very
social people so being able to indulge
in that again and kind of bring out this
whole other aspect of kink in our lives
has been really fun because I was
my last relationships were all very
vanilla so to walk around
um and have a caller put on me and he'll
literally put the leash on me too and
it's like that's how I wear my like
that's how I am the whole party and he's
got the leash in the hand unless he
gives it to me and it's it's kind of
funny just because I love doing it so
much and I wonder
like I wonder where that fetish came
from because I think that all like all
fetishes have a psychological connection
somewhere either to trauma or your
childhood in some way there's some sort
of connection and given that like I'm
like where the hell did that one come
from you think the sexual abuse that you
went through as a kid somehow plays into
this I uh I definitely do to a certain
extent I know that
different aspects of it have come into
play in like the pornography that I like
to watch and things like that and
um I think as as I've been explained it
by my therapist
um years ago it comes down to
sometimes it's about reenacting the
abuse almost but this time you have the
control that you didn't have back then
now you are taking control of an
experience and you give to give yourself
that power back and relive it the way
that you've always wanted to relive it
and give yourself that kind of
um because if I if I say stop I know
he'll stop
and that's one of those things that I
may have been because I also know that
my mother was physically abusive
and I enjoy
certain types of physical pain during
sex and I know that again that that
comes down to that I know that if I say
that's too much and pull back he's there
too whether it's him doing it or someone
else that he'll be there to protect me
and keep that from escalating to a point
when I can no longer enjoy it
and giving myself that enjoyment during
the experience gives me that freedom
to let go of that like past trauma
because I understand that it happened
and I didn't enjoy that experience but
now I have this experience to overlap
with that same response if that makes
sense and so that way I don't have to
worry about
the pain that I suffered because that
pain can also be correlated with
pleasure
have you ventured off a little bit too
far for your comfort level
um
not not quite yet I think in the past
um I had indulged in some role play
online and things like that that had
definitely ventured way into
uncomfortability you know stuff like
with certain people and I ended up just
cutting that um that aspect out for a
while just because it wasn't I didn't
have a trusted partner in which I could
have that
um that role play with without it
getting to a point of this is
not what I'm talking about whatsoever
like type thing and
it got to
it it just became kind of like something
that it was no longer enjoyable and it
was no longer related to my trauma and
it was creating a whole new trauma at
that point communication is key isn't it
so what advice would you give to
somebody who's
curious about this polyamorous lifestyle
um baby steps first uh there's and
communication is
Paramount
um if your partner is not okay with
polyamory
it comes down to you you either need to
understand yourself and not engage in a
you know
non-ethical way
um
but also
it's it's about being able to understand
yourself without necessarily forcing
your partner to be in an uncomfortable
you know position for themselves because
I understand that
some people are not built for polyamory
some people are just not going to
understand it and it's gonna it's gonna
cause them pain and even people like
myself like I've been polyamorous my
whole life I I didn't know that that's
what I was but I I am
and there are going to be times that
monogamy is necessary to gain trust and
to gain that kind of like connection
with your partner
and when those times are necessary you
have to decide is my Venture into
polyamory what's most important or is it
my need to have a connection with this
person because that is going to come
into play at some point you're going to
have that like
that internal Battle of I really want
this but
I how much more do I want that than do I
want them and
unfortunately like with my past
relationship because it was sexually
unsatisfying as well as emotionally and
financially unsatisfying
venturing into the polyamorous lifestyle
when he wasn't
really into it was definitely something
that became more important to me
because of the fact that he was abusive
and neglectful and
this idea of not even being able to be
myself in that relationship or even talk
to him about it without being a fight
that was where I felt like everything
kind of started to go downhill and
I think for me it was
really hard to come to terms with that
because I do see my own toxic behavior
in that and my own selfishness
but
you're gonna need to be selfish
sometimes in your life and that's part
of the advice I would give too is that
sometimes it's okay to be selfish I
think that if you've tried to talk to
your partner about it and they're just
not receptive and not understanding and
that there's no reasons
why they that if you can give them
options on how to feel secure and
connected and you still get to indulge
in your own needs and they're not
willing to do that you have to make that
selfish Choice somehow because
suppressing yourself your whole life is
only going to lead you to like being
miserable
and I would know I mean I was there I
was in with him for 11 years and I
suppressed myself and 90 of that
relationship
and it was miserable
even though I cared a lot about him and
we were both very much alike in in our
humor and a lot of things and I still
look back and think wow I really lost
like my one of my best friends when
everything went down between us
I was never happy because I was so
suppressed and I couldn't be myself
and because of that
everything you know blew up in our faces
and
and that and many other reasons but
um
I would definitely say that if if you
have the option
and
you need to be selfish it's okay to be
selfish sometimes but it's not okay to
just indulge in a selfish lifestyle 24
7. I think that there's a definitely a
very fine line of when it's okay and
when it's not and I think that that line
changes for every person
and every dynamic because every
polyamorous relationship is going to be
different
and that's probably another piece of
advice to give is that you have to
figure out where you are where they are
and where you both can kind of meet in
the middle but also
understand that nobody else is going to
be able to understand your Dynamic quite
like you guys can because the only two
people that matter really are the the
ones in the relation or not two people
the only people that matter are the ones
in the relationship if you add another
person into the dynamic they matter as
well and their opinions matter and what
they need in the relationship matters
and you have to be able to indulge in
that and you have to feel like some
they're both indulging in that for you
as well and that's the only way a
cohesive unit is going to be able to
form and have that Foundation of a real
like because what I've always wanted is
a kitchen table poly which is you know
everybody can kind of live in the same
house we all you know chip in for the
responsibilities and we can all go and
engage outside or inside the home
however we please
and we're all very accepting of that
and to be able to have that kind of
relationship you have to have a
foundation of trust and connection and
that is the only way that I think that
you can do it is by listening and trying
to meet their needs and having and then
also being willing to let them meet your
needs because I think that that's
something that we all struggle with
is just being okay with somebody else
like knowing that vulnerability of us
and then letting them indulge in it
all right Nicks thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much for
having me I wish you and your fiance a
lot of great Years thank you